The chief executive has got
to be bold within reason
and daring in application.
I recognize very
few people watching
this will become president.
But I think you'll find
lessons in leadership that
will apply to your life.
As president, sometimes
I had information
that the American
people didn't know.
And therefore, I had
to make decisions,
what was best for the
country, on knowledge
that wasn't evident.
That's just the
nature of leadership.
So long as you're
guided by principle
and so long as you're guided
by a cause greater than self,
you can endure criticism.
Because it's gonna come.
One of the things I missed
after the presidency
was this daily learning.
And, thankfully, painting
came into my life.
It's a learning experience
because, with every paint
stroke, you learn something new.
All right, I'm gonna
do another flower.
It's important to have a set
of priorities that guide you.
And your team, your
company, your managers,
have got to understand
those priorities.
To me, the most
important priorities
were my faith and my
family and my friends.
That may sound corny
to some, but it
helps you reorganize
the rest of your life.
Welcome darling.
LAURA: Thanks.
Great.
Glad to be here.
GEORGE: When I was
speaking to audiences,
I didn't want them to think
I was smarter than they were.
One of the keys to
communication is
to figure out how to
enable the person you're
talking to to relax.
You know, I was a
master at the malaprop.
Misunderestimate.
The press corps reaction
was, "Did the guy really
just say that?"
[CHUCKLES]
I remember, right after
9/11 in the Oval Office,
talking about
praying for families
that had suffered loss.
I broke down in tears.
If your heart is
touched, let people know
that your heart is touched.
Not everybody is
gonna be a leader,
but everybody can end up
being a better person.
The challenge of
life is not to attain
wealth and status and power.
The challenge of
life is to improve
and to learn to love better.
And everybody can do that.
I'm George W. Bush, and
this is MasterClass.